[Música]
entramos a Back mood a finales de
diciembre de 2022
esta ciudad se ha vuelto el frente más
activo y violento de la guerra en
Ucrania
[Música]
la ciudad está dividida por el río
magnutka Los ucranianos defienden
firmemente el oeste al este los rusos
han logrado entrar hasta los suburbios y
combaten con armas ligeras en las calles
ambos bandos han instalado puntos de
artillería las afueras de la ciudad que
disparan día y noche
estos soldados ucranianos regresan del
frente situado a una centena de metros
[Aplausos]
la información es secreta
puedo decirles que les estamos
disparando y ellos responden los hemos
hecho retroceder un poco todo va bien
cada batalla es una tragedia
una muerte es la vida de una persona Su
futuro
el futuro de su familia
Ucrania vencerá este edificio es el
punto de evacuación de los soldados
heridos
los nuestros están disparando
están muy cerca
200 metros máximo
quieren tomar la ciudad a causa de las
vías
es una ciudad importante para ellos
si la toman podrán atacar
no podemos permitir que hagan eso
después de haber vivido durante meses
bajo los bombardeos los civiles parecen
insensibles a lo que ocurre a su
alrededor
las personas pasan por aquí todos los
días no tienen miedo se ríen
para ellos la situación se ha vuelto
normal
salga De esta zona por favor que hacen
aquí hay bombardeos
Era una ciudad con 70.000 habitantes
antes de la guerra pero se transformó en
un campo de batalla
ya no hay agua ni electricidad tampoco
gas ni red telefónica Ana nikolai y sus
tres hijos se dirigen hacia uno de los
puntos de ayuda humanitaria de la ciudad
las personas vienen aquí para usar el
internet contactar a sus seres queridos
cargar sus teléfonos calentarse y tener
un poco de compañía
un proyectil cayó nuestro edificio no en
nuestro apartamento sino en el de los
vecinos mi esposo y yo tuvimos que pagar
solos el incendio mi escuela quedó
destruida estudiaba en la escuela número
si quieren evacuar puede ofrecerles una
casa es un buen sitio
los propietarios la están dando en renta
puedo llamarlos ahora mismo
es un muy buen lugar ideal para los
niños
sabemos que hay personas generosas que
están dispuestas a ayudarnos
Pero más adelante estarán en la misma
situación que nosotros y después serán
ellos los que necesitan ayuda por ahora
los combates son aquí pero pueden
extenderse y llegar hasta allá también
el voluntario no pudo convencer a Ana y
su familia para que se fueran
[Música]
las personas están viviendo en sótanos
lo único que tenían era la radio rusa
pasaron mucho tiempo sin acceso a la
información
les dijeron que sus esposos serían
reclutados a la fuerza en el ejército o
encarcelados les dijeron muchas cosas
más del 90% de la población
la vida es difícil para los que se
quedan y algunos terminan por Rendirse
como Angelina
es Horrible Horrible nos bombardean uno
camina preguntándose cuándo caerá el
próximo proyectil vivimos cada día como
si fuera el último es aterrador el
ambiente sofocante psicológicamente
quiero irme porque no puedo hacer nada
más aquí quiero irme simplemente para
poder ducharme Perdón por decirlo así
en el apartamento donde vivía Angelina
cayó un proyectil hace tres días
Estas son las ventanas del apartamento
Esta es la cocina Esa es la habitación
Donde dormíamos había una cama grande
ahora hay vidrios rotos por todas partes
y los muros se desplomaron
[Música]
no podía oír nada la onda de choque me
dio en el lado derecho y cojeaba
este ataque hizo que Angelina y maxime
su compañero tomaran la decisión de
evacuar batmut la joven ya había tenido
que irse del apartamento de su familia
seis semanas atrás
Esta es mi casa
el edificio se derrumbó después de un
ataque la mayoría de los residentes
murió por casualidad la familia de
Angelina no estaba en casa ese día aquí
murió gente estaban atrapados debajo de
los escombros sacaron unos cuerpos uno
de los bomberos también murió
Disculpen es duro me dan ganas de llorar
casi toda mi familia se fue y yo también
quiero evacuar pero mi padre quiere
quedarse si se va será a Rusia
no pensamos igual yo soy una patriota en
mi familia evitamos hablar sobre ese
tema
en esta región rusoparlante la guerra ha
dividido a las familias entre Pro rusos
y procranianos
Angelina nos dijo que su padre es un
hombre muy devoto este domingo nos
dirigimos a la iglesia ortodoxa afiliada
al patriarcado ruso para tratar de
encontrarnos con él
[Música]
la misa se celebra en la cripta a la luz
de las velas Alexander el padre de
Angelina asistió vino a comulgar
acompañado por dos de sus hijos
[Música]
radio
Alexander acepta llevarnos a su casa
vive justo en medio del campo de batalla
el proyectil cayó aquí nuestra ventana
estalló tuvimos suerte mucha suerte
la mayoría de los trozos salieron
volando hacia allá
tuvimos suerte de que la explosión fuera
de este lado
[Aplausos]
Alexander y sus hijos se han organizado
para sobrevivir bajo los bombardeos
ya estamos más o menos acostumbrados
pero al principio no podíamos dormir
era aterrador la casa temblaba todo el
suelo se movía como si fuera gelatina de
verdad parecía gelatina la guerra partió
a la familia en tres
la esposa de Alexander se refugió en
Rusia con su nieto Angelina quiere
reunirse con su otro hermano procraniano
en el oeste Alexander dice que se
quedará aquí con sus otros dos hijos
para mí Ucrania Bueno si quieren
llamarlo Ucrania es un solo y mismo país
con Rusia y velarus es un mismo pueblo
es un árbol con distintas ramas pero con
la misma raíz es doloroso Angelina es mi
punto débil creo que no quiere volver a
vernos
nadie la obligó a irse fue su decisión
nadie la echó a ella no le gusta nuestro
estilo de vida que era la libertad
la Libertad en el mal sentido de la
palabra
[Aplausos]
en la ciudad de los soldados ucranianos
han reforzado sus posiciones
literalmente se han enterrado en las
trincheras que cavaron en pleno centro
si quieres vivir cavas
entre más profundo sea más posibilidades
tienes de sobrevivir
estas trincheras son nuevas nosotros las
estamos terminando hicimos unos
resquicios en caso de que se arrastren
hacia nosotros
para que podamos tener buenas posiciones
de tiro
en el este de la ciudad los combates no
dan tregua
los ucranianos dicen que han logrado
retomar algunas cuadras haciendo
retroceder a los soldados rusos y a Los
mercenarios del grupo paramilitar Wagner
deben estar drogados
o tener el cerebro totalmente
es horrible para orcos
las situaciones complicada los
eliminamos pero vuelven una y otra vez
como cucarachas
tenemos muchas pérdidas muchos heridos
el ejército ucraniano no comunica su
cantidad de pérdidas pero las
ambulancias se evacuan día y noche a los
soldados heridos hacia los hospitales
militares de la región
[Aplausos]
han llegado cinco ambulancias en tan
solo una hora
aquí nos dicen que reciben una centena
de soldados heridos al día
fue un proyectil de mortero me arrancó
la pierna
eso fue qué puedo decir
estoy bien me duele la pierna pero
aparte de eso estoy bien
y después empezaron los tiros cuando se
volvió muy intenso
todo el mundo se escondió en las
trincheras
sentí un dolor muy fuerte y supe que una
de las explosiones me había alcanzado
traté de mover mis dedos se movían pero
supe que los huesos estaban rotos porque
Se oía un crujido
[Música]
los combates más duros son los de
bakmuth es el infiernos
el infierno
a la mañana siguiente ha llegado la hora
de irse para Angelina y maxim nos
encontramos con ellos en un sótano donde
tienen sus maletas listas
[Música]
estoy contento por alejarme de esta zona
de guerra pero me entristece abandonar
Mi ciudad creo que Volveré algún día
unos voluntarios conducen estos buses
que recogen a los civiles cerca de la
línea del frente para evacuar los
gratuitamente hacia zonas seguras hoy
Angelina y maxim Son los únicos
pasajeros a veces hay dos personas otras
veces hay 15 depende
El problema es que no hay red de
telefonía entonces venimos todos los
días a la misma hora y también recogemos
a las personas que lograron contactarnos
[Música]
ayer lloré es muy duro no tengo ganas de
irme pero no hay trabajo no hay dinero
tenemos frío y hambre todo el tiempo
quiero vivir no solo sobrevivir próxima
parada la gran ciudad de Nitro 260
kilómetros al oeste
allí Angelina y maximo deberán
reconstruir su vida mientras esperan que
la paz regrese
A las afueras de la ciudad acaba de caer
un nuevo proyectil la universidad está
en llamas